bledsoe guarding white
williams lost his footing but levine's
there out to white trying to get him
involved early and there's kobe white
here's kobe right here you see zach
recognized kobe struggling
and got in the ball immediately where
you just catch and shoot
you know for his size his fat lever oh
nice call yeah
oh what a shot
what's this right here just a step back
lowry marketing so young playing the
five spot
levine another three the [ __ ] catch
and shoot off a single double
wide open ingram ball heart and then jj
redick and billy airnon gomez in
zach levine come out on we talking about
give me the hot sauce
saucy
[Music]
five to shoot levine has the space
give me a little bit of a slog for him
shooting hasn't been for levine tonight
at the hash mark josh hart's like i dare
you to shoot it
oh i will valentine the floater
rims out there's young with an offensive
rebound pitch to kobe that's a three
yes oh bang bang bang all set up by the
rebound by
thaddeus young here he is staging
johnson with the kick out
valentine behind the screen long rebound
arch with the rebound
white's going to try it again comey
white bang bang bang
little laflamma blanca here in the first
half when the bulls needed it
denzel setting up zach that's a corner
three open and good
saucy 27 in the first half said hey we
got to work on your mechanics you got to
move the ball from your hip to your
forehead be a little bit more
conventional
and it's worked out great and zach
levine keeps on
shooting his seventh three of the game
at least in the double team yeah adams
and ball went over to levine
temple out to white for three give me
the hot sauce
kobe needed a game like tonight
here's gafford out to levine wide open
shot fake to get ball in the air and
buries another three
oh my goodness sriracha follow jason
goff on twitter he was asking about
blocking three-point shooters it
happened so rarely
oh white a deep one oh stop it
here they go picking up what they did in
the first quarter 18
three pointers this one the latest the
fourth from kobe white
he's got
in the big picture hoping for the same
for the bulls good ball movement again
white ends up with it and ends up with
another three his third of the quarter
stacy
ball and they get that high number of
assists they're tough to beat
white from temple again oh give me the
hot sauce kobe
kobe white he's got space
[Applause]
his cases of hot sauce all in the united
center tonight my goodness
williamson lost his footing good defense
by williams
young to temple to levine that's a 40
piece for zach levine
give me the hot sauce with that 40 piece